so is there any circumstances in which
you would consider higher pay
settlements for those public sector
workers who are struggling with
circumstances which your government and
predecessors have helped create well um
we have invested record sums in the NHS
in our schools and we want to back them
to the help because they have a very
very important job to do for the country
and we'll talk about absolutely anything
to resolve these strikes accept measures
that will entrench high inflation and we
don't think strikes are helpful they're
very damaging they're very disruptive we
think the best way to resolve these
issues is to sit and talk and find a
solution that doesn't entrench the very
inflation that is upsetting so many
people plenty of economists will say
that there's no danger of wage price
spiral from public sector wages are you
saying there is no more money forget it
get back to work there's no chance of an
increased payoff well we should listen
to the very clear warning from the bank
of England Governor yesterday who said
that if you fund higher wage settlements
through borrowing that is inflationary
and that's why it's a very difficult
situation we want to get in back into a
situation where people's real wages are
growing but the one thing that we
shouldn't do if we want that to happen
is to do something that digs in this
High inflation so is that a no to more
money it's not a no it's saying we'll
talk about absolutely anything except
things that will dig in the very high
inflation that is causing people to see
the the cost of their weekly shop go up
and the value of their wages erode as
well as
below inflation pay Rises if you're in
the public sector people also facing
across the board huge pressure on energy
bills you're about to put energy bills
up by withdrawing support in April
wholesale gas prices are falling this is
not as expensive as you would have
initially thought is there any way
you'll reconsider that withdrawal of
support and give people help with energy
bills through the spring well we are
doing absolutely everything we can to
help families through this difficult
period we're giving about three and a
half thousand pounds of support on
average to every family in the country
this year and last year so it's it's a
massive amount of help about 99 billion
pounds but we also have to be
responsible with public finances because
if we're not we just give them a
different pressure Which is higher
interest rates so you won't reconsider
that well we look at everything we can
do but we won't do things that leads to
higher interest rates because that just
creates a different pressure